hallo zusammen und schön dass sie wieder
dabei seit heute habe ich ein
riesenthema maxi king für euch und es
schmeckt nicht nur sehr lecker es ist
auch originalgetreu ohne biscuit sondern
mit waffeln
die gibt es in jedem gut sortierten
supermarkt in der russischen abteilung
außerdem brauchen wir 1000 gramm
mascarpone 160 gramm puderzucker 100
gramm magermilchpulver findet ihr auch
in ihren gut sortierten supermarkt es
geht zwar auch ohne aber mit schmeckt es
einfach viel originalgetreuer dann
brauchen wir noch 800 gramm sahne 300
gramm geschmolzene freundlich kuvertüre
80 gramm haselnüsse 18 teelöffel seiner
tat das entspricht 140 gramm und eine
dose gezuckerte und karamellisierte
kondensmilch die gibt es auch schon
fertig zu kaufen
optional könnt ihr noch karamell sirup
verwenden
die perfekte maxi king form hat in
meinem fall diese ovale auflaufform die
s 35 cm lang und 24 cm breit und die
lege ich jetzt mit frischhaltefolie aus
die frischhaltefolie dient dazu dass man
das maxi king später leichter aus der
form nehmen kann
darüber gebe ich jetzt als kleber die
geschmolzene freue mich kuvertüre
allerdings erstmal nur die hälfte und
verstreiche das ganze mit meinem pinsel
anschließend nehme ich mir meine waffe
und schneide sie mir zurecht
sobald meine waffe dann perfekt in die
vom rhein fast bestreite ich sie noch
mal mit kuvertüre und lege sie umgedreht
in die form hinein
und macht euch überhaupt keine sorgen
wenn die waffeln lieber mir brechen das
sieht man im anschnitt überhaupt nicht
mehr
anschließend kann ich noch die seiten
mit den waffeln einkleiden und lege das
zum kühlen in den kühlschrank
in der zwischenzeit berate ich schon mal
die leckere creme vor
dafür schlage ich die sahne mit dem
sommerbad steif und gäbe dass bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
ich verwende hier übrigens 18 löffel
sommerbad also nicht wie im video
gezeigt viel lasst euch davon bitte
nicht irritieren
in eine separate schüssel gebe ich die
mascarpone und dann das magermilchpulver
dazu und vermische das ganze mit dem
mixer
dazu gebe ich jetzt noch einen schuss
karamell sirup wie gesagt das ist nur
optional aber ich finde dass es die
creme sehr aromatisiert
dann wird der puderzucker hineingeriet
damit auch keine klümpchen entstehen und
nochmal ganz gut unter gemixt
jetzt werden noch die restlichen zehn
teelöffel seiner fahrt unter gemixt
damit die creme auch schön fest ist und
danach können wir schon die sahne
unterheben
nachdem die sahne unter gehoben wurde
ist die maxi king kleben auch schon
fertig und ich sage euch die schmeckt
wirklich original wie im maxi king für
die karamell creme im inneren werde ich
jetzt noch die 80 gramm haselnüsse fein
mahlen und am besten so lange malen bis
die textur ein bisschen cremiger wird
ich würde auf diesen schritt auch nicht
verzichten weil nur die karamell themen
schmeckt ein wenig langweilig und
nachdem ich das dann getan habe gebe ich
die haselnüsse zusammen mit der karamell
creme in eine schüssel und vermische das
alles miteinander
nun nehmen wir uns die vorbereitete maxi
king form aus dem kühlschrank und geben
da die hälfte der creme hinein
die creme wird aber auch gleichmäßig an
den rand versprechen damit da genug
platz ist für die karamell creme und sie
die waffe nicht berührt wie im original
maxi king
jetzt gebe ich auch schon die leckere
karamell creme in die mitte und
verstreiche sie glatt
gebe alles nochmal für ca 10 minuten in
den kühlschrank damit das schön fest
wird jetzt kommt auch schon die zweite
hälfte der maxi king bremen drauf und
wird glatt verstrichen
schließend gebe ich dann nochmal eine
schicht waffeln darauf die ich mir
bereits zurecht geschnitten habe und
dann gebe ich den rest der kuvertüre
darauf kuvertüre ist inzwischen schon
hart geworden aber ich habe sie noch mal
ganz schnell die beim wasserbad erwärmt
das ganze gebe ich jetzt noch mal den
kühlschrank bis die kuvertüre schön fest
wird
zum bestreichen und für die deko
benötigen wir noch 300 gramm gehackte
haselnüsse die habe ich gerüstet und
abkühlen lassen
600 gramm vollmilch kuvertüre und 60
gramm palmen
dadurch kann man hinterher dass maxi
king viel besser aufschneiden damit
später nicht der ganze küchentisch
eingebaut ist nämlich mit zwei bank
papiere zu hilfe und nehme mir dann ein
paar gläser damit ich da drauf dann beim
maxi king platzieren kann welches ich
gerade auch aus dem kühlschrank genommen
habe ich empfehle euch auf jeden fall
frischhaltefolie und nicht alufolie zu
benutzen denn die bekommt ja auch
restlos ab geschmolzene kuvertüre gebe
ich jetzt über das maxi king und
verteile das schön gleichmäßig mit
meinem pinsel
direkt im anschluss gebe ich da drauf
die gehackte haselnüsse und verteile sie
gleichmäßig falls einige stellen der
zwischenzeit getrocknet sein sollten
könnt ihr sie noch mal mit der flüssigen
kuvertüre einstreichen
maxi king war bei mir noch mal kurz im
kühlschrank damit alles schön fest
werden kann und wie ihr sehen könnt ist
im original maxi king die haselnuss
schicht nicht so ganz zu sehen weswegen
ich sie jetzt nochmal mit kuvertüre
einstreichen
unser xxl maxi king ist auch schon
fertig und sofort servieren bereit und
ich schneide es noch mal schnell für
euch an damit ihr auch seht wie es im
innern aussieht und die creme sowie das
äußere mit der waffel schmeckt wirklich
originalgetreu ist es wirklich überhaupt
keinen unterschied zu schmecken sehr
lecker er bekommt damit vielleicht 20
bis 25 personen satt und falls ihr mehr
solcher videos sehen wollt dann würde
ich mich sehr über euro freuen
bis zum nächsten mal okay hieß kitchen